rights groups say Iraqis held captive at
the infamous U.S run Abu ghraib prison
and other facilities are still waiting
to get Justice it's been more than 20
years since the U.S led Coalition
invaded Iraq now Human Rights Watch
accuses Washington of failing to provide
compensation to Iraqis who were tortured
by American forces
around a hundred thousand Iraqis were
detained between the years of 2003 and
2009. many say they continue to suffer
from the long-term effects of that
torture
American guards were seen simulating
acts of sexual abuse on naked inmates
caused cases of beatings and prolonged
sleep and sensory deprivation were also
documented
often International outcry 11 U.S
soldiers were convicted of being
involved in abuses at Abu graib
but most American Service members who
were accused of carrying out the acts of
torture were reprimanded without being
charged
Human Rights Watch track down a torture
Survivor this is Talib al-majli's story
detailing the physical and mental of
suffering he still struggles with to
this day
the car
is
um
electrical money foreign
foreign
's mental and physical health
deteriorated
he started to self-harm by biting his
hands and arms
foreign
researcher Human Rights Watch who
tracked the Survivor that we just
listened to we spoke to a little earlier
and she says some steps have to be taken
by the US government for Meaningful
accountability
the U.S did take some steps to prosecute
mostly low-ranking soldiers after the
abuses were committed but unfortunately
we didn't see any officers held
accountable under the command of
doctrine of command responsibility
which is something that the U.S has
failed to do and unfortunately
unfortunately we also haven't seen
prosecutions of perpetrators coupled
with redress to their victims
we're calling on the U.S government to
do three main things the first is that
it needs to review all allegations of
abuse and investigate cases based on
transparent criteria
second it needs to initiate prosecutions
against anyone found to be involved
regardless of their rank or position and
finally it needs to open a pathway where
survivors can come forward and make a
claim to have their case heard by the US
government to receive compensation
apologies and other forms of redress
well we can speak now to Hoda Abdul
Hamid who joins us now live here in the
studio holder you were in Iraq reporting
on the war in the early 2000s was it
common knowledge what was going on in
abuco
well there was knowledge that
torture was going on in Abu rape that
detines were randomly captured held
without charge mistreated but I don't
think anyone
expected that
what was happening when those pictures
came out I remember it was like a shock
wave I was in Baghdad at the time it was
a shock wave already Among Us in our
little workspace and then anyone you'd
speak to would say we could not believe
that that was happening because it was
extremely humiliating and even more so
uh when you are in Iraq and you know
about the culture and you know about
certain sensitivities and people would
tell you that that was specifically done
uh really to humiliate The Prisoner uh
to the core and I think it was also
the last show after that the U.S
probably lost all support it still had
some some people believed that you know
things we could get better getting rid
of Saddam Hussein changing regime and
all of that but I think after those
pictures came out and the shock wave it
it really provoked around the country uh
the U.S lost all support we're just
showing some of those pictures now
they're still so devastating to look at
all these years on I mean you spoke to
American soldiers as well as senior
military commanders about what happened
what was their response well
when the Scandal broke the Bush
Administration was trying to sell it as
the making of a few bad apples well we
then spoke to some soldiers after they
left Iraq we also spoke to some senior
officers of the U.S army and they denied
that they said it was actually
systematic they said that there was a
general in charge Jeffrey Miller he had
he had been the general in charge in
Guantanamo and then he had been moved to
Iraq and the first thing he said when he
arrived is that those prisoners were
treated too well and they had to be
treated much worse to get any kind of
confession out of them because remember
at the time outside of the prison there
was a what the U.S were calling an
Insurgency that was
picking up momentum day by day the Iraqi
call it resistance but the U.S was
trying to figure out what was going on
it was at a loss it was an election year
back in the U.S George Bush really
needed to have nice pictures nice
stories coming out of Iraq and then this
rape scandal comes out and completely
backlashes it actually has the complete
opposite effect if the idea was to
torture
prisoners to get some kind of confession
and to get things back on track well
that did not happen all it did is that
the resistance picked up momentum groups
like Al-Qaeda picked up momentum the
Islamic State which was right there at
the beginning with Abu musab al-zakawi
picked up momentum and
um you know and these people we spoke to
told us it was orders and actually you
have Declassified documents that show
that the
defense Donald Rumsfeld Secretary of
Defense at the time in the U.S had
actually also sanctioned this kind of
interrogation technique they call it
enhanced interrogation techniques but
those pictures show that there was no
interrogation whatsoever going on at
that time it was simply
really about humiliating these prisoners
many of whom left and were released
without any charge and that is something
we have to remember it's a good point I
this was 20 years ago and yet here we
are so many years later why has it been
so difficult for victims to get Justice
well I think it's just because it's
going to open a can of worms because
once the those who were held in in Abu
rape start getting compensation uh then
you'll have those who were held in
guantano Guantanamo Bay who are going to
ask for the same thing you have those
who were part of these rendition
programs and programs whereby prisoners
were flown to a third country with
someone from the CIA with them on
Military praise to be tortured in that
third country to get confessions out of
them so I think once you start this
compensation you probably will have
hundreds of people behind that asking
for the same thing and probably that's
why the U.S is reluctant about opening
that door okay
first in Doha thank you